la elección de joe biden codivara brasil
para retirar las súplicas hacia afuera y hacia adentro
relaciones con los estados unidos por lo
listo el presidente de brasil esta ahi
Bolsonaro tenderá a moderar su tono
críticas contra los demócratas allo
lugares de broma donde se llama al comunista
y el domicilio social
sila l'armir sal para que compartas
bolsonaro oye de donald trump
incluyendo muchos Sveno analista político
un paralelo entra en la ranura del presidente
especialmente porque no sé mucho de los
noticias falsas me quedo en la pared que
bolsonaro y esperaba buena forma
la victoria de biden me gustaría quedarme no
ambos presentes y no pronunciados la
la semana pasada por encima de la fabulación
sede de fraude electoral que trump a y que
esta en proceso electoral
No estoy ahí como sé a distancia bolsa
Me refiero a texturas que nos arrastran
persona pero hay algo importante en el mundo que
pero persona importante del mundo es
dios tambien espero que el reporte
siempre el sdo espía explota una certeza
sobre un tema concretamos el
preservación de la baronía brasil gna
biden en diciembre en ocasión schenone
los temas darán un impulso particular
presión internacional por encima del
gobernador de brasil para che non si ga
destruyendo el masoni incluido mucho
y la sed pero es en el premier deber el
presidencial del momento Bordonaro no
aunque se pronunció mocoso
especialista en pantalla que no es Bordonaro
corrección en política exterior y del
exterior quiere convertir y un igual a
internacional viene ste cambio de
rumble abrió a dos victim claras y el
ministro inferior el ministro de la media
ambiente